à 8 km de la frontière avec la Russie le
village ukrainien de loupiane
occupé au premier jour de l'invasion
russe le 24 février libéré par l'armée
ukrainienne le 11 septembre
sur 1200 habitants 450 qui sont restés
survivre grâce à l'aide humanitaire et
avec l'arrivée de l'hiver l'inquiétude
s'installe
le principal problème maintenant c'est
comment passer l'hiver sans gaz sans
électricité et sans os est impossible il
y a beaucoup de vieilles personnes et de
malades alités si seulement ils
apportaient au moins du bois
à 81 ans vit seul avec son mari cloué au
lit par la maladie de Parkinson
[Musique]
je n'ai pas de quoi le raser il n'y a
pas de rasoir j'en ai commandé aux
soldat aujourd'hui
regardez j'en avais plein je les ai tous
utilisés j'allais en demander au soldats
ils ne m'ont jamais refusé tout je fais
tout moi-même
dans ces zones bouclées par l'armée il
manque aussi de médicaments
[Musique]
cela où vais-je les trouver désormais
surtout yakaterina cherche le moyen de
passer l'hiver
je ramène l'eau du puits pour cuisiner
et faire la lessive et là je veux mettre
le lit parce que si je cuisine grâce à
une bonbonne de gaz la chaleur ira aussi
dans la pièce
après l'intensité des combats
l'infrastructure dans certaines zones
libérées et totalement détruites les
autorités ukrainiennes disent réparer ce
qu'elles peuvent entre les mines les
tirs incessants dépassés par l'ampleur
des dégâts